you intrigued me wolf kiss orphan and
sibling Warrior and
poet you are many in one it
seems a he
good I missed you brother Randy your
husband returns bringing gifts and
riches to share and new friends I
see we cannot stay in Norway not without
fuel more war so we push
forward a new kingdom
awaits from here to Valhalla I will
always be on your side
sigur
always aore
sigur I give you
England this land already has many
rulers from the cunning King Alfred of
Wessex to the warmongering sons of
Ragnar Luth Brook they have no wish to
share the kingdoms they have made their
[Music]
own I do not fear these
men nor any others who would harm
[Music]
us these lands bring our people hope
I will do whatever it takes to make
England our
[Applause]
home the Saxons hunger for no
[Music]
blood let's give them a taste
Brothers these conquests have given you
a home but there is more more to this
land aore a Darkness unseen an
unknowable threat one bound to England's
Destiny and to
yours